no matter who's making America great now
50 years old on driving a truck and I'm
gonna be happy because there's gonna be
11 percent growth in the next five years
then all of a sudden bang ups bang
American Express poster service uber
automated you're all fired
what am I gonna do then because I'm
sitting here telling you that America's
gonna be great I'm gonna be good forever
yeah I mean look at that that's going
political like anybody anybody that
thinks the present United States whether
it's Barack or Donald or Bernie or
Hillary is gonna help them they're
[ __ ] loser
straight up I promise you you are that
means you need some like so like whether
you're whether you're president is for
minorities and females or your president
is you know for the 26 year old white
male that's got no skills here's the
punchline the market is the market what
does the 54 year old gonna do adjust or
loose right but how do we keep up how do
we get that message out to say you know
what you could probably drive talk to
your 55 you can program and tech and
doodle to your night you talking to BMW
they said that they can't get enough
kids to be to be technician because if
theory is the old the own the old
mechanic would the big grease on his
shirt I was talking to the head of heavy
machinery operations meaning crane
operators they said their jobs are empty
for 15 months these kids can go to
school for one year come out make
$150,000 but yet they're going to a
school 50% of them will retire with the
title of a job that doesn't exist today
they're staying in school for four years
happens digital classes they're leaving
with a $300,000 of debt and they still
don't know how to operate anything so
how do we get the parents in this room
to save that money how do we get the
kids in this room
well not the kids in this room but who's
gonna watch us online to understand what
they need to do move ahead and nothing
but diploma is gonna save me the
president is gonna save me well there's
gonna save me or anything else how do we
what happens in what needs to happen
carnage
carnage needs to happen people are
complacent heroes most people strategies
in life I mean I really have no passion
for this conversation like if you are
not capable in 2017 to Google [ __ ] and
figure out what's going on in the world
[ __ ] you I'm being dead serious like
what role does the government play or
thought leaders or this enact whatever
that cliche statement of like the
teacher comes when the student is ready
right I believe in that thing like like
I don't know like I'm not lots of things
happen like lots of things happen in
life right I woke up one morning and
realize you know what this liquor
shipping law is never gonna get better
there's dirty politician money they're
gonna keep paying this off and I'm not
gonna spend the rest of my life worrying
about what the right thing to do is and
what's right no they're gonna keep
paying off politicians state by state
and because I'm the biggest I'll always
be picked on so i justed I started over
I started over like I started over like
this whole Wine Library thing and I got
so lucky guess what I own zero percent
of Wine Library because it was under my
father's name so I had no collateral to
even start it started Waner media by
getting somebody to pay me eighty
thousand dollars to do a marketing
campaign and i built it and so that's
what's gonna happen and everybody has
their version not everybody has my
business talent to build billion-dollar
companies but if you're making seventy
four thousand or one hundred ninety
seven thousand or whatever you're making
and your market gets [ __ ] I don't see
truck driver Johnny feeling bad for Rick
the bookstore owner cuz Amazon came
along this happened this has happened
forever he's not the first time the
innovation [ __ ] [ __ ] up nobody's
crying for the farmers in Middle America
nobody's crying for the people in
Cleveland who own the docks this is what
always happens so this is what's up now
and so what 55 year old Charles has to
do when he is out of a job is get
another job whatever that job is so if
Charles is smart and has skills he's
teaching himself something now
to be ready for three years from now but
Charles wants to watch football but
Charles wants a drink at the bar
so Nene's acquit is 20% into what's
going on in the future and I start
that's right and bank that you're damn
right
[Music]